another day drawing to a close in
Westminster
and the mood darkening as strikes
continue and the government tries to
clamp down on them
[Music]
you say power Union outside on Whitehall
protests
[Applause]
inside Parliament MPS discuss new laws
to maintain minimum levels of service
the strikes minimum service level bill
will ensure that we protect the ability
of workers to take industrial action but
they will also protect the public from
disproportionate disruption that one
person's right to strike doesn't
infringe on someone else's right to life
and live
the opposition unconvinced I cannot
recall a measure that is at one so
irrational and so insulting not only is
it vindictive addictive assault on the
basic freedoms of British working people
but this legislation is as empty of
detail as it is full of holes
politicians divided but the union
steadfast of course if the government
don't come to the table we will continue
to take action this morning the GMB
Union representing ambulance workers
meeting to discuss a further series of
strike dates and the mood musics not
good what were the discussions like is
everyone sort of resigned to the fact
that you are still in a standoff and
stalemate with the government overpay
there's a huge amount of Anger from our
members working in the ambulance service
and from their representatives that
Steve Barkley is not taking this
seriously our members are saving lives
day in day out our members will not back
down in this fight and they need to stay
frankly to actually take them seriously
what the fact that you've got so many
new laws to curb strike in Stoke
intentions father they're taking away
our right to strike because they can't
get the pay right to keep our members to
keep the staff in the NHS lives are
being lost because of the way that the
government's run in the NHS at the
moment strikes to continue across our
schools and Health Service next month
it's heartbreaking actually that nurses
have been pushed to this position and
it's tragic and I do want to apologize
to any patient that will have any of
their care or treatment canceled on the
day of industrial action but what those
nursing staff are doing is standing up
for their passions and saying we need to
find a resolution to this
resolutions for now not on the cards as
the country's patients wait for
resolution and it's public set to
workers fight on Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster